c'est aux côtés de sa ministre de la
culture audrey azoulay que françois
hollande a inauguré hier la réouverture
de la maison d'emile zola fermé pour
travaux depuis 2011
l'écrivain avait pu s'offrir cette
demeure grâce au succès de son roman
l'assommoir dans une allocution de près
d'une demi heure
le président a rappelé les combat
humaniste de l'écrivain mentionnant à
plusieurs reprises l'espoir qu'il avait
nourri tout ça lui même dans la nuit la
plus sombre lui toujours une espérance
même dans le grainage d'une machinerie
infernale
il suffit d'une voix une seule pour
changer le cours des choses et le destin
des hommes
une perspective que le président
pourrait bien souhaité pour lui même à
quelques mois de la fin de son mandat en
conclusion comme un écho à son propre
parcours
il a tenu à rappeler l'essence même de
tout combat politique
voilà notre responsabilité face à
l'histoire ne pas s'abandonner à la
fatalité à la facilité avoir le courage
de faire le choix justes qui n'est pas
toujours le plus populaire et le plus
gratifiant
d'autres personnalités invitées ont
aussi rendu hommage au grand homme
en prenant justement fait et cause dans
l' affaire dreyfus il a donné ses
lettres de noblesse et les lettres de
noblesse donc à la république qui
s'était quelque peu égaré un magnifique
discours en l'honneur des d'emile zola
et de son combat pour la république la
justice contre toutes les formes
d'intolérance de discrimination prévu à
proximité de la maison zola un musée
dreyfus devrait ouvrir ses portes en